[Musik]
[Applaus]
bedeutet Gouverneur, wir erlauben keine
Steuererhöhungen und wir werden niemals eine
Einkommenssteuer haben, mach dir darüber keine Sorgen, aber ich
muss ehrlich sein, ich denke, dass meine
Aufzeichnungen gut sind, denke ich.  Ich bin eine natürliche
Wahl, aber ein Grund dafür, dass wir
so viel Unterstützung bekommen haben, ist, dass sie
den Gegner Andrew Gilliam
ansehen und Angst davor haben
, was das für die öffentliche
Sicherheit in Florida, das wir als Bürgermeister kennen, bedeuten würde
Tallahassee, er hat es versäumt,
Tallahassee zu beschützen, sie hatten
viele Jahre lang die höchste Kriminalität in Florida. Die Art und Weise, wie
er den Präsidenten unterstützt, ist auch
wichtig für mich, weil ich denke, dass der
Präsident in Bezug
auf viele Dinge, die die nationale Sicherheit der Einwanderung betreffen, auf dem richtigen Weg ist
Unsere Verbündeten stellen
sicher, dass Amerika weltweit stark ist. Was
denkst du? Ich habe es geschafft. Ich liebe sie.
Ich mag die Art und Weise, wie er sich den Menschen entgegenstellt.
Er lässt sich nicht schikanieren
warum nicht
ich meine ich hab mir die Prentis h angeschaut  Er ist
kein Rassist, seine Leute in seinem Ministerium,
jede Farbe, Religion, er ist kein Rassist.
Ich denke, Details sind wichtig, und wenn Sie sich ansehen,
was der Präsident tatsächlich sagt, ist es
nicht rassistisch. Ich denke, die Presse und
die größere demokratische Körperschaft
nehmen seine Worte und  sie verzerren sie zu
ihrem eigenen politischen Vorteil
[Applaus]
Andrew Gilliam ist ein engagierter Linker
Andrew glaubt nicht an den zweiten
Verfassungszusatz, tatsächlich hat er gesagt, oh die
Kriterien, was würden Sie verbieten, wenn Sie sich ansehen,
was er sagte, das wäre wie das
Weite  Die Mehrheit der Handfeuerwaffen und
Langwaffen Mir geht es zu 100 Prozent um den
Schutz unserer Grenzen. Eine Nation ist keine
souveräne Nation ohne sichere Grenzen.
Ich bin nicht dagegen, dass mein Großvater ein
Einwanderer war, aber er kam legal aus Schottland in dieses Land
über die Grenze schleichen und unsere Gesetze brechen
[Applaus]
[Musik]